Galaktoboureko and baklava are traditional
Greek desserts.
Although several European and Middle Eastern
countries have versions of baklava, most
consist of phyllo pastry filled with nuts
drenched in honey or syrup.
Galaktoboureko is phyllo filled with custard
and coated with sweet syrup.
This variety of baklava called Berma is made
not with phyllo dough like classic baklava,
but with kataifi shredded wheat dough.
Berma like classic phyllo baklava contains
whole pistachios, never pistachio powder.
This Berma chef pours granulated sugar over
the pistachio kernels.
Next, he sprinkles rosewater.
Although this ingredient is optional.
Then syrup made with sugar, water, cinnamon
and nutmeg as well as lemon to prevent the
sugar from later crystallizing.
He mixes by hand to thoroughly coat the
kernels.
The kataifi is made of all purpose flour,
milk and water.
The chef lays out a section of dough, then
takes a handful of pistachio filling and
places it on the dough, forming a line
running down the middle for a Burma loaf this
size. The filling is about an inch wide and
high.
He folds the end closed and rolls the dough
at an angle down the length of the Burma,
tightly encasing the filling as he goes.
At the end, he folds the opposite end
closed.
It takes a Burma chef months to perfect this
technique.
He places it on a tray to air dry for 24
hours to ensure the dough maintains its
rolled shape. Unlike classic baklava, which
is baked, Burma is fried, and the risk of
burning the pistachios makes this the most
technically challenging type of baklava to
make. The chef fries the loaves for three
minutes in oil heated to around 350°F,
turning them once per minute.
He lets the oil drain off for half an hour.
Then he pours warm, caramelized sugar over
the loaves and lets them soak for 20 minutes.
The sugar to water ratio and the boiling
time of the caramelized sugar have to be just
right. Otherwise it will become either too
hard or too gooey when it cools.
After letting the excess drain off the
loaves rest for about three hours.
Then the chef rolls the loaf to flatten out
the bumps and slices it into equal pieces.
But if there's a protracted battle waging
between your sweet tooth and your willpower.
You've got plenty of time to work your way
through a box of Burma because it stays fresh
for two weeks.
To make galaktoboureko.
The chef begins with two ingredients milk
and semolina.
After bringing the milk to a boil, he
gradually adds the semolina while whisking
and lowering the temperature.
Once the mix thickens, he sets it aside to
cool.
In a separate bowl, the chef whisks eggs,
adds vanilla, then lemon or orange rind.
Other options are orange blossom or
rosewater extract.
He transfers the ingredients to an electric
mixer, adds butter and sugar.
Then he adds the semolina and milk mixture.
This mixture must be cool so that the eggs
don't cook.
Once everything is thoroughly blended, the
Galaktoboureko custard is ready.
The chef now turns his attention to the
phyllo dough.
He stacks 24 parchment, thin sheets of
phyllo and slices them into squares.
He places one scoop full of custard in the
center of each square.
The traditional Greek way is to roll the
squares or bake a large galaktoboureko in a
pan and then cut it into squares.
However, this chef folds over each square to
make Lebanese style triangles.
He douses the top with clarified butter
butter that's been boiled to separate out the
solids and leave just the oil.
Then he bakes the pastries for 45 minutes at
325°F.
The golden baked top shines thanks to the
clarified butter.
The chef cooks the same syrup he made for
the baklava.
Sugar water, cinnamon, nutmeg and lemon and
generously drizzles the mixture all over the
galaktoboureko as he sprinkles on cinnamon
for traditional flavor and some crushed
pistachios for decoration.
Kimchi is Korean comfort food.
The zesty blend of fermented vegetables has
been part of the Korean diet for at least
2000 years.
It's so valued by Koreans that some even
have special refrigerators for it in their
homes. Like fine wine, kimchi must be kept
at a specific temperature to be at its best.
The kitchen staff carves the cabbage into
fairly large strips because cabbage is thin.
Bigger strips will ferment at the same pace
as the shredded carrots and diced scallions.
The next ingredient is ginger, a spice that
will add flavor and soothe the digestive
system. Another worker transfers the
shredded ginger to a porous cotton bag.
She folds the bag a few times to create a
packet and then places the packet under a
press. The press squeezes juice from the
ginger and extracts the ginger essence while
leaving the stringy pulp behind.
The worker weighs the ingredients, beginning
with the shredded carrot.
This is the largest ingredient after Napa
cabbage.
She then measures the portion of scallions
that the recipe calls for.
She adds a scoop of Celtic sea salt and
checks the scale.
Other ingredients include crushed garlic.
Chili flakes and the ginger juice.
She stirs the seasonings into the vegetables
and the ginger juice begins to saturate the
scallion and carrot pieces.
All the ingredients now come together in
this mixer with a big dough hook.
The worker adds The carrot and scallion
blend to the Napa cabbage in the base of the
mixing bowl. She activates the mixer and the
dough hook folds all the elements together.
Fermentation begins, triggered by the evenly
distributed salt.
Workers, then transfer the mixture to
special fermentation crocks and pack it down.
Two half circle ceramic weights add pressure
to the salted ingredients.
Juices flow and immerse the kimchi
vegetables, creating an oxygen free
environment. The salt suppresses the growth
of bad bacteria, allowing the good bacteria
to flourish. Another worker pours water into
a moat around the lid, creating a ring of
water that acts as a kind of seal, one that
will keep air out of the crock, but will
allow fermentation gases to escape.
One week later, the kimchi is sufficiently
fermented.
It is now a living food full of good
bacteria.
A worker packs the kimchi into jars and
weighs each container to confirm that the
amount is correct.
The jars must be completely full with no air
space between the kimchi and the lids that
could compromise its shelf life.
She labels the jars and shrink, wraps a
plastic collar around the lids.
Once refrigerated kimchi can last for up to
14 months.
Well preserved.
It's practically always ready to be served.
Carlsons are a traditional French candy made
of almonds, candied melon and orange peel.
Topped with a thin layer of hard, typically
white icing.
The first step in the production is to
rehydrate the almonds with steam for about
ten minutes so that they can be worked into
a paste.
Once the almonds, moisture content is
increased by 2 to 4%, the almonds pass over a
vibrating screen to drain any water
resulting from steam condensation.
Meanwhile, this cauldron heats up liquid
beet sugar.
France is one of the world's largest sugar
beet producers, so high quality beet sugar is
readily available.
Workers transfer the hydrated almonds to a
grinder and add candied fruit.
95% melon and 5% orange peel.
This flavor is the 500 year old traditional
recipe.
Workers grind the ingredients for about ten
minutes until everything is thoroughly
blended into a coarse paste.
The pace drops onto a conveyor belt, which
transfers it to a kneading machine into which
workers add the hot liquid beet sugar and
natural almond oil made from bitter almonds.
Kneading blends the ingredients and smooths
the texture of the paste.
A worker boxes the Carlson paste and sets it
aside for three days to let the sugar mature
and stabilize.
Carlsons are topped with an ever so thin
layer of royal icing.
Unlike creamy icings, royal icing is as hard
as a rock.
To make it. A worker combines icing, sugar
and whipped egg whites passed through a
strainer. A mixer beats the ingredients
until the mixture is thick and smooth, which
typically takes about ten minutes.
After three days of rest, the paste is ready
to be worked.
Shaping and decorating the collections is a
specialized task.
Entrust it to these experienced artisans
called Kali Sanders.
First, they place slices of paste in a press
and load a mold underneath.
They cover the mold with a wafer thin sheet
of unleavened bread.
Then the press piston descends, forcing the
paste with the bread layer underneath into
the mold. They skim off the excess paste,
then fold the stencil over the mold and apply
the layer of royal icing.
They lift off the stencil and push the
buttons which activate the mold pistons.
Each piston pierces the base of a caisson
and lifts it out of the mold.
Finally, they remove the Callsigns with
combs designed to fit around the Pistons.
A ten minute trip through a tunnel oven set
at low temperature bakes the royal icing to a
hard and shiny state.
By combining protein and vegetable elements
with rice in a bowl, people have a meal.
It's Asian comfort food and somehow it just
tastes better in a bowl.
And people around the world are discovering
the appeal of these one bowl meals.
Asian bowl meals.
Start with the rice.
Then people add whatever they want.
At food bars like this, there's any number
of choices.
The bowls can be served up fast and the food
is healthy because there are many possible
combinations. These one bowl meals never get
boring preparation.
Start with the rice.
This food worker measures enough for 40
portions.
After rinsing the grains repeatedly, he adds
it to a rice cooker.
He then measures the water for cooking.
He adds it to the cooker.
It will steam the grains so they cook
uniformly for one hour while the rice is
cooking. The food worker then pours peeled
garlic cloves into a food processor.
He adds A half cup of vegetable oil.
The garlic will flavor several dishes in the
Asian food bar.
The food processor chops the garlic to a
fine consistency.
Using a mandolin vegetable slicer.
He slices slivers of carrots along with
chopped onions.
The carrots will enhance the flavor of fried
rice.
He now removes some rice from the cooker in
order to make fried rice.
He separates the grains so they'll fry more
uniformly.
The food worker is now ready to fry.
He heats the wok to a very high temperature.
He adds cooking oil and it starts to sizzle.
He tosses in the carrot slivers, chopped
onion, garlic and frozen peas.
He constantly stirs the ingredients and the
flavors sweeten and deepen.
He turns down the heat a bit and adds the
rice.
He mixes the rice with the other ingredients
as the cooking continues at a slightly lower
temperature. He measures the temperature for
food safety reasons.
It needs to be over 143°F.
The food worker pours soy sauce onto the hot
wok.
It trickles down to permeate the rice,
adding flavor and color.
That completes the fried rice component of
the food bar.
Next up are the vegetable and protein
choices.
The food worker cube, sushi grade tuna.
It will be marinated with a spicy sauce
shortly.
He places the tuna in a food bar container.
He peels cucumber, and then Julie ends it.
The cucumber will be a raw food choice that
will offset the strong flavor of the tuna.
The food worker then prepares the tuna spicy
marinade.
He adds chili sauce and a smaller amount of
chili oil to mayonnaise.
It's hot stuff.
A seaweed salad dish is another refreshing
choice that will cool the palate.
He adds the chili mayonnaise to the tuna,
and he turns up the heat a little more with
some extra chili oil.
A thorough mixing completely saturates the
raw fish with the spicy sauce.
Next, the food worker prepares a dressing
for a cabbage salad.
He starts with a white miso paste.
A generous amount of soy sauce follows.
Sushi, vinegar and vegetable oil are the
next ingredients.
After adding some sesame oil, he blends all
the components.
He coats the shredded cabbage with the miso
dressing.
He sprinkles black sesame seeds onto the
cabbage salad.
Teriyaki beef is the next option.
The main ingredients are shaved fillet
steak, chopped ginger and shredded onion.
The food worker sortase the onion and ginger
to provide a flavor base.
He adds the shaved steak, and as it cooks,
it takes up the essence of the onion and
ginger. The soy based teriyaki sauce
provides the final layer of flavor.
With this dish now complete, it's time for
the fun part.
Mixing and matching components for the Asian
food bowl.